hallo zusammen heute mal aus einer
anderen Perspektive denn ich bekomme
immer so viele Nachrichten von euch
gerade so über Instagram Direct Message
das und dieses schief gegangen woran
liegt und ich schreibe auch mit ganz
vielen von euch privat und gibt dann
immer Tipps und dann habe ich mir so
überlegt warum mache ich das nicht für
alle also habe ich auf Instagram die
meisten backfails jetzt bimmelt mein
Ofen ich bin sofort wieder da ein Tipp
schon mal von mir macht immer die
Stäbchenprobe bei einem Biskuitboden und
ich zeige euch mal wie das funktioniert
das passt jetzt nämlich gerade ganz gut
ich bin mir jetzt nicht sicher ob dieser
Kuchen 24 26 oder 28 Minuten braucht
also habe ich erstmal 24 Minuten
gestellt und jetzt kann ich einfach
überprüfen ob der gar ist in dem ich mir
so einen Schaschlikspieß den nehme ich
auch immer wieder und mache ihn sauber
einfach in die Mitte reinsteche so und
wenn dann nichts dran kleben bleibt so
wie hier ist der perfekt gar gebacken
wenn ich ihn jetzt noch länger backen
würde dann würde er zu trocken werden
also nehme ich ihn einmal raus Deck ihn
auch in der Oberfläche ab damit der auch
nicht tro wird und dann geht es aber
wirklich los mit dem Video so wir haben
versucht eure Fragen jetzt in Kategorien
einzusortieren und falls euch im Laufe
des Videos oder am Ende des Videos noch
mehr Fragen einfallen dann schreibt sie
in die Kommentare dann reicht es ja
vielleicht noch für einen Teil 2 und
Sarah wenn du bezaubernde Assistentin
hinter der Kamera stellt mir jetzt eure
Fragen
[Musik]
wie bekomme ich die Buttercreme für
Torten weiß Butter wenn man sie schlägt
wird schon sehr sehr hell man sieht es
auch jedes mal meinen Videos von Vanille
gelb oder so Eierschalen gelb auf beige
oder so ein so ein off-white aber so
ganz ganz weiß bekommt man das nur wenn
man noch mal extra Farbe hinzufügt da
muss man aufpassen dass es keine
flüssige Farbe ist weil er sonst die
Konsistenz der Buttercreme sich
verändert und vielleicht dann nicht vor
euer Projekt geeignet ist weil ich
wollte ja auch irgendwie Rosen spritzen
oder sowas sondern ist sie einfach durch
die Zugabe von flüssiger
Lebensmittelfarbe zu flüssig daher rate
ich da immer zu einer Lebensmittel
gelfarbe in weiß und davon braucht ihr
dann recht viel je nachdem wie viel
Buttercreme ihr habt aber es ist
definitiv machbar dass man sie dann
durch Zugabe von lebensmittelgel Farbe
weiß bekommt meine Buttercreme wird nie
so glatt da sind immer Bröckel oder
Luftbläschen drin mit bröckelig meinst
du wahrscheinlich in grisselig oder dass
sie halt gerinnt das passiert auch mal
und das kann man dann einfach retten
also wenn die Buttercreme so kleine
Stückchen hat und ihr das Gefühl habt
ihr müsst sie wegschmeißen könnt ihr
einfach ein paar Esslöffel so einen
kleinen Teil der Buttercreme über einem
Wasserbad erwärmen und dann nach und
nach zur restlichen Buttercreme
unterheben und so lange schlagen trust
the process wie man so schön sagt
einfach so lange schlagen bis sie dann
wieder richtig schön geschmeidig wird
und nicht mehr gruselig ist hast du ein
alternativrezept statt Buttercreme und
eine Torte von außen einzustreichen
viele nehmen ja oft zum Hintergrund
viele nehmen ja Buttercreme bei
dekorativen Dingen oder wenn etwas
einfach vielleicht standfest sein soll
weil ihr müsst euch vorstellen
Buttercreme ist bei Wärme wenn sie auf
dem Kuchenbuffet draußen steht auch
schnell schnell warm und weich aber
viele finden da halt einfach ein Ansatz
um dekorative Torten darzustellen
Röschen zu spritzen oder die Buttercreme
einzufärben und einfach schöne Muster
drauf zu spritzen aber man könnte
stattdessen auch immer was ich immer gut
finde Sahne Mascarpone Creme verwenden
weil Mascarpone so fest und man kann da
so mit dem Geschmack spielen weil es
schon relativ neutral schmeckt dass man
einfach Großteil also zwei Drittel
Mascarpone ein Drittel Sahne dazu die
Klassiker wie Sahnefest und Puderzucker
nehmen und das auch einfach zum
Bestreichen ausnehmen da könnt ihr aber
jetzt nicht so krass dekorativ unterwegs
sein dann gehen dann meistens nur so
Tupfen oder einfach so Dinge die man mit
Tüllen machen kann
was tun wenn Schlagsahne zu lange
geschlagen worden ist also wenn sie dann
krisselig geworden ja dann kann man
nichts mehr machen tatsächlich dann
könnt ihr nicht den Trick bei der
Buttercreme anwenden und das Erwärmen
das funktioniert gar nicht weil Sahne
braucht es immer ganz kalt und da machen
viele Backanfänger den Fehler dass die
Sahne schon weil sie einfach schon die
Zutaten aus dem Kühlschrank nehmen die
Sahne steht dann schon mal eine
Dreiviertelstunde ach die Schüssel spüle
ich noch mal mit warmem Wasser ab das
ist der absolute Tod für jede Sahne
daher muss immer alles richtig schön
kalt sein auch wenn ihr haltbare Sahne
nehmt im Tetrapack auch dann 12 Stunden
vorher in den Kühlschrank stellen zeig
mal deine Kühlschrank da steht ich würde
sagen es kommen noch einige Fragen zu
Sahne daher nehme ich mir jetzt mein
Becher Sahne und wir schlagen jetzt mal
auf und ich zeige euch die häufigsten
Fehler und wie man so umgehen kann also
ich habe jetzt hier ganz kalte
Schlagsahne die kommen gerade vor 30
Sekunden aus dem Kühlschrank den
Schlüssel hier kommt auch aus dem
Kühlschrank das ist noch mal so ein
kleiner zusatztipp wenn ihr euch ganz
sicher gehen möchtet Schüssel und auch
schneebesenaufsatz in den Kühlschrank zu
stellen für zehn Minuten dann ist
nämlich auch schön kalt und dann ist das
einfach die perfekte Ausgangslage um
Sahnesteif zu schlagen das ganze
funktioniert natürlich auch mit einem
Handrührgerät genau das gleiche Prinzip
dauert halt nur ein bisschen länger und
ihr müsst halt immer dabei stehen es
würde auch mit einem Schneebesen
funktioniert aber ich glaube das macht
heutzutage echt keiner mehr weil es ja
echt super anstrengend ist so und jetzt
ist die Frage wann merke ich dass meine
Sahne steif ist und nicht dieser kleine
Grad von steif auf geronnen kommt das
zeige ich euch jetzt indem ich erstmal
anfange zu schlagen erstmal auf geringer
Stufe weil wenn jetzt direkt volle Power
macht dann spritzt euch das halt überall
hin und ich gebe auch immer wo Sahnefest
dazu wenn die Sahne so halbsteif ist das
heißt man merkt die ist noch nicht ganz
steif fällt auch noch so vom Schneebesen
das zeige ich euch gleich in dem Moment
gebe ich Sahnefest dazu
[Musik]
so es ist der halbsteife Zustand
erreicht worden das zeige ich euch mal
das ist jetzt so der Moment wo ich dann
Sahnefest dazu gebe es ist schon dicker
geworden aber auf jeden Fall noch nicht
fest und ihr könnt es immer so rechnen
dass ihr ungefähr ein Teelöffel
Sahnefest pro 100 g Sahne verwendet in
einem so einem Päckchen das ist ja
glaubst du das bekannteste aus dem
Supermarkt sind zwei Teelöffel drin und
dann gibt sie immer zwei Teelöffel pro
Becherchen 200 g Sahne mit hinzu habe
ich jetzt zwei Becher drin einfach rein
das müsst ihr nie sieben das ist schon
so fein dass ihr das einfach nicht sehen
müsste entstehen niemals Klümpchen und
dann einfach weiter schlagen und wenn
ihr merkt das ist so also fast steif ist
aber noch nicht ganz ich habe immer so
ein Trick dass ich dann so von zehn
runterzähle ich hoffe das ist vielleicht
ein hilfreicher Tipp für euch so mache
ich immer so 10 9 8 und so weiter und
dann schaue ich mir das an und wenn es
dann noch so ein paar Schwünge
gebrauchen kann dann mache ich das aber
immer dran bleiben und nicht irgendwie
den Raum verlassen weil es geht so
schnell dass die griselig wird jetzt
habe ich noch mal ein toptip für euch
dass ihr euch wirklich sicher seid eure
Sahne ist steif und ihr müsst sie nicht
weiter schlagen wenn ihr die Abdrücke
von eurem Schneebesen seht weil sie die
sieht man nicht wenn es noch flüssig ist
irgendwann machen die sich in dem Kreis
bemerkbar dann sieht man so Striche und
die sind dann erstmal weit und die
werden dann irgendwann sichtbarer ab da
könnt ihr schon diese 10 Sekunden
runterziehen jetzt habe ich noch so 5
Sekunden vor mir wir halten gleich noch
mal die Kamera rein man sieht auf jeden
Fall definitiv die Abdrücke vom
Schneebesen ist ein Indiz dafür dass es
fest ist wie gesagt ich zähle noch mal
runter und dann nehme ich immer noch
einmal den Schneebesen haltet in die
Luft und guck ob da so feine Spitzen
sind ist es wird nicht steinhart aber es
sind so feine Spitzen von der Sahne und
dann ist die Sahne fest und wenn ihr
dann noch weitere fünf oder zehn
Sekunden schlagt dann gerinnt sie und
die kann man nicht mehr retten
[Musik]
welche Tortencreme für welchen Boden
kann man gar nicht so pauschal sagen
weil jeder Boden verträgt sich auch mit
jeder Tortencreme man kann ein fluffigen
Biskuitboden mit einer reichhaltigen
Buttercreme kombinieren man kann aber
auch diesen saftigen
Schokoboden der auch schon so
reichhaltig schmeckt auch mit
Buttercreme kombinieren oder aber mit
einer locker fluffigen Creme also das
Mixed und matscht eigentlich alles
zusammen wieso wird mein Zuckerguss nach
dem Erkalten manchmal wieder zu Zucker
kann es sein dass du dann einen Schuss
Zitronensaft vergisst weil sie einen
Schuss Zitronensaft ist ganz wichtig für
den Prozess also immer Wasser Zucker und
ein Schuss Zitronensaft dann sollte dann
nichts schief gehen Karamell wird
entweder klumpig oder verbrennt immer
trotz Videoanleitungen oh Karamell ist
eine richtig feinfühlige Sache erst
denkt man oh das karamellisiert nie dann
geht es alles super schnell weil man
ungeduldig ist und die Hitze herstellt
bei Karamell ist es drin man muss sich
manchmal je nach Rezept schon 15 bis 20
Minuten Zeit lassen und bei einigen
Rezepten ich habe auch verschiedene
karamellrezepte darf man auch gar nicht
in der Pfanne rumrühren also man muss
wirklich geduldig bleiben und wenn es
dann zu schnell verbrennt ist es immer
ein Indiz dafür dass die Hitze zu heiß
gestellt war mein Karamell wird fest
nach der Kühlung was mache ich da falsch
manche Rezepte sind ja so ausgelegt dass
die nach dem kühlen fest werden
vielleicht hast du dann einfach das
falsche Rezept für deinen Zweck also ich
habe zum Beispiel auch karamellrezepte
die sind wenn so warm sind in der Pfanne
fließt das Karamell richtig aber ich
möchte dass es dann nach dem Kühlprozess
wieder fest wird dann hast Du genauso
ein Rezept und dann würde ich beim
nächsten Mal einfach mehr Sahne nehmen
dann ist es ein bisschen flüssiger meine
Creme ist nie hart genug obwohl ich sie
immer nach Rezept mache das habe ich
auch manchmal also manchmal wir wenn wir
drehen haben wir auch alle Lichter etc
an die geben mir auch Wärme ab das ist
wie ein warmer Sommertag und dann merke
ich dass meine Creme auch nicht fest
genug ist und dann heißt es kühlen
kühlen kühlen auch eine eine sahne Creme
zum Beispiel die ihr einfach zum
Befüllen verwendet wenn ihr merkt okay
die ist noch relativ weich vertraut mir
eine Nacht in den Kühlschrank und die
wird richtig fest als als wäre Gelatine
oder sowas drin dann müsste einfach ganz
viel kühlen da führt kein Weg dran
vorbei da braucht man einfach Geduld bei
deinen Cremes warum gibt man masc vorne
und Schlagsahne meistens getrennt hinzu
also es gibt solche und solche Rezepte
ich habe ja einfach in den letzten
Jahren gemerkt weil ich irgendwann mal
auch ich hatte da Zeitdruck irgendwas
war und dann wollte ich einen Mascarpone
Sahnecreme machen und dann habe ich
gedacht was passiert eigentlich wenn ich
beides zusammen in die Schüssel gebe
also Mascarpone dann die Sahne und dann
fange ich erstmal langsam an zu rühren
dann verbindet es sich und dann ruhig
immer schneller das Ergebnis war es
wurde fest und es wurde genauso fest wie
als wenn ich sie getrennt voneinander
schlage je nachdem was für weitere
Zutaten dazu kommen mag ich es einfach
trotzdem noch Mascarpone zum Beispiel
mit geschmolzener weißer Kuvertüre
erstmal vorab glatt zu rühren und dann
die Sahne steif zu schlagen das kommt
einfach immer aufs Rezept an und man
muss auch sagen viele Wege führen nach
Rom das heißt es gibt gar nicht diesen
geraden einen Weg wie man eine Sahne
Mascarpone Creme macht sondern manche
mögen es lieber getrennt und machen das
lieber gehen auf Nummer sicher und
andere trauen sich zu alles zusammen in
der Schüssel zu verrühren kann man deine
creams ohne Stimme immer Aufwärmen in
der Mikrowelle damit erkalten lassen
oder werden die dann schlicht
also meine creams kann man alle bei
geringer Wattzahl also nicht ganz so
gering aber 600 Watt ohne Deckel in der
Mikrowelle für ein paar Sekunden
erwärmen dann werden sie fließfähig dann
könnt ihr sie zum Beispiel als Glasur
oben drüber verwenden das kennt der von
meiner
haselnusscremetorte und dann wird meine
Creme auch wieder wie ein Brotaufstrich
also wieder ein bisschen geschmeidiger
und fester und dann könnte sie immer
wieder erwärmen die Creme wird dadurch
nicht schlecht was passieren kann je
weniger Inhalt das Glas hat umso weniger
Sekunden müsstet ihr es in der
Mikrowelle erwärmen und einige haben
dann die gleiche sekundenanzahl im Kopf
wie wenn das Glas voll ist und dann kann
es sein dass euch da oben mal was
anbrennt und das wäre dann super schade
daher je weniger glasinhalt desto
weniger Sekunden erwärmen so ich hoffe
dass euch dieses Video gefallen hat und
falls ihr weitere Fragen habt immer
immer gerne unten in die Kommentare und
dann sehen wir uns auch bei meinem
nächsten Video tschüss eure Kiki
[Musik]